welcome back it's racked up over 70
million views online since it launched
in 2014
yes Carmilla certainly has taken a bite
out of the vampire romance genre don't
worry I got more of those I'm here with
star Natasha
Naga vilanis who won the fan Choice
Award at the 2017 at Canadian Screen
Awards and not to brag for you you can
do that on your own
Wow well I try not to now the viral of
vamp sensation is so successful it got
turned into a movie for hit theaters for
one night only back in October and now
the feeding frenzy continues with its TV
movie premiere on Hollywood suite
tonight now this franchise is insane can
you believe with the success that has
had I am continuously surprised by how
big it's been when we started shooting
Carmilla back in 2014 it was this tiny
little low-budget digital series that
played on YouTube we shot in this tiny
little room Oh
Carmy okay there is something very wrong
with this blood now it's a feature film
and people all over the world are
watching it and it's just surpassed
everybody's wildest dreams do you think
you'd get
[Music]
did you really think that be neuquén
sequences in fact the series existed
online I think that had a lot to do with
its success how it was able to spread
absolutely I think because it was able
to reach a global audience and also
because the fandom around it was able to
create their own community and I think
what's really nice about digital is that
it is able to reach people in countries
where being queer is still illegal
unfortunately or where there is no
same-sex marriage and so I think it was
really special in that regard because
people were able to see themselves
reflected on-screen yeah kind of
messages do you get from fans all over
the world actually you know what from
parents saying thank you for showing my
kid that they're not weird or that it's
okay to be different or to live your
truth and that's really meaningful and
really special to me when I'm attic fan
convention and people are there with
their parents do you want to see these
characters continue their stories yeah
well the film did end with a bit of a
cliffhanger but I have no idea what else
is in store I mean I love carmilla's so
so dearly so I'd be so happy to do a
second film